un froid polaire là dehors tu as
souffert laisse tomber quand j'attendais
le bus j'ai cru que j'allais gelé sur
place un voile blanc recouvrait la vue
du sang tête ont même quitté ton corps
n'ont quand même pas non tout disparaît
c'est autour de toi et la morsure de
l'hiver planter ses crocs dans tes
entrailles sa valentine
j'ai une solution pour toi c'est à dire
les pins quoi est-ce que tu connais les
expéditions sharks ou non n'ont pas bien
non c'est quoi le rapport bas le froid
la peur de mourir et les pingouins
pourquoi charcot c'est un gars qui
attendait le bus avait pas grand charles
causé un grand explorateur qui est parti
à la conquête des pôles et en arrivant
au pôle sud
la situation est grave le docteur
charcot ne peut s'empêcher de répéter la
terrible phrase de dante ou vous qui
entrez mais c'est là toute espérance
mais cette mélancolie tombe bientôt à
l'aspect des pingouins graves comme des
pères dominicains qui accueille avec une
tranquille philosophie la troupe des
explorateurs à charcot parle de
pingouins mais en réalité ces démons
chaud c'est quand même cool d'être
accueillis par des bestioles tranquille
quand tu visites une région aussi
hostile oui c'est toujours mieux que tu
fais un mauvais parent horse
il n'ya pas d'ours au pôle sud il n'ya
comme gibier que des phoques et des
pingouins a les yeux de pain voit
qu'elle omelette on en faisait le matin
et qu'elle flanc le soir et puis le
pingouin et enchanté quand je fasse
sauter au beurre il paraît qu'il met
point habitués à ce qu'on le tue aussi
se laisse-t-il faire avec une douceur
exquise
on approche comme on veut et on lui
offre du chloroforme
donc un trouver la sensation si agréable
qu'il mourrait en chantonnant parce que
le pingouin en plus de se laisser buté
et cuisiner est un fin mélomane les
pingouins adore la musique
un jour on leur fit entendre des
morceaux d'opéra excellemment rendu par
un phonographe parisiens et les pins
noirs après avoir entendu la voix de la
salle exprimèrent leur joie en exécutant
une sorte de danse et en poussant au
putsch en scène en vue d'adopter un
petit pingouin n'importe quoi le
pingouin sa vie en société avec d'autres
pingouins t par un pingouin
oui atteint super sens de l'observation
je suis pas la seule
l'expédition a beaucoup apporté à la
science en ramenant nombreux
échantillons plus de 500 variétés
microbes des fleurs terrestres et
marines ils ont étudié les marais du pô
le magnétisme
ils ont même cartographier la région
parti qui est très impressionnant
ils ont également étudié de près la
sociologie des pommes séchées que les
pingouins font des monos me dise la
prière du soir traces des routes
construisent des villes etienne des
congrès auprès desquels ceux du parti
radical socialiste ne sont que de pâles
restant est une question essentielle se
pose alors quels souvenirs ou à laisser
tu veux dire dans l'éventualité où les
pingouins se raconte des histoires le
soir au coin du feu dans les âmes et
puis les siècles s'écouleront les
légendes se transmettront de génération
en génération de pommes en quelques
morceaux de bois conserver commis deux
seront montrées aux pingouins esprits
forts qui haussant les épaules voudront
douter qu au parce qu'un pingouins ça
doute
moi quand je pense à ces petites bêtes
qui affronte l'adversité polar avec
autant de courage ça me fait une sorte
de fûts soir ouais mais ils n'ont pas
froid les pingouins mais bien sûr que si
ils ont froid
et c'est parce qu'ils ont froid qui me
réchauffe le coeur
[Musique]